Kim Kardashian may not always agree with
hubby Kanye West but she'll always
support him there was a circus on
Saturday a Kanye West led circus last
week the 41 year old rapper went off
script
following the season 44 premiere of
Saturday Night Live Kanye West performed
on the show and afterwards he gave an
unplanned speech to the audience in
support of Donald Trump Kanye said that
Democrats broke up black families with
welfare and that's slavery is not real
you know how wrong about politics you
have to be for like me to notice he's
since deleted all his social media
accounts but despite the backlash a
source tells et that all is well in the
West's household
the source tells ET quilt
although Kanye has been supporting
President Trump on SNL with his hat and
through his Twitter his wife Kim
Kardashian and him are great Kim doesn't
always agree with everything Kanye says
when it comes to politics
or other things but she respects him
being vocal about what he believes in
the source adds that Kanye who recently
changed his name to Yee has helped Kim
be more vocal about what she believes in
and they both understand when they don't
agree on something but it's healthy and
makes their relationship stronger
et previously reported that Kanye's
stepped in as the musical guest after
ariana grande dropped out due to
emotional reason and Grande's fiance
Pete Davidson went off on the rapper
during Saturday's Weekend Update segment
there is and I'll tell you in a way that
Kanye understands I made this make Kanye
2006 again a second source tells et that
Kanye is struggling again and the
Kardashians are all worried and they
never know what his next move will be
according to the source
Kanye seems to have visions of grandeur
and actually talks about becoming the
next president the source adds quote
it's hard to tell how much Kanye is
serious about it because it seems as if
he absolutely loves the attention
Kim is playing at smart and quietly
allowing Kanye to be Kanye the family
just hopes things will quiet down with
Kanye and things don't get worse